From the Library of
Congress from Washington DC.
Good morning!
I'm Carla Hayden, the
Librarian of Congress and I want
to welcome you to this
very special Story Time
at the Library.
I love reading, don't you?
It's so much fun to let
our imaginations run wild.
We're excited to be teaming
up with Ms. Dolly Parton's
Imagination Library
to introduce you to
some wonderful authors
who will share their
stories with us.
Ms. Parton's work through
her Imagination Library
is awe-inspiring!
She and her team have given
away over 100 million books
to help encourage young readers
like you across the world.
Here at the Library of
Congress we share that passion
for developing young readers!
And we know that the best way
to encourage people like you
to read is to make reading fun!
So that's what we're here to do.
I hope you enjoy
today's story time!
Even more, I hope you keep
reading at home and having fun!
Today, you will warm up
by singing some songs,
touching your toes, and
then get comfortable
and get ready to hear stories.
Now let's get started!
Welcome, my name is Ms.
Caroline and welcome
to the Whittall Pavilion
of the Library of Congress!
So exciting so we're gonna
start with our Hello song
and a little bit of signing
let me show you hello
you do a salute hello
okay
hello
and then friends
you're going to link
your index finger one way
and then the other way
okay
friends
hello friends
so we'll do that three
times and then it's time
so you're going to touch
your imaginary watch
and then to say hello
okay
and the tune is goodnight ladies
la Lala la Lala la la la la
okay
here we go
hello friends
it's time to say hello
one more time
hello friends
it's time to say hello
good job
okay
so let's do our usual warm-up
open
shut them
okay
here we go
open
shut them
give a little
oh them
open shut
put them in your lap
creep them
crawl them
right up to your TV
chichi
open wide your little mouth baby
one more time
oh then
you shut them
open
shut them
give a little back
Oh baby
shut them open shut them
put them in your lap
creep them
crawl them
right up to your chin
okay
we'd like to welcome Rachel
Isadora and her daughter
up to read the first book
I just which we're
doing this one first
hi come up,
hi want to sit here?
you can sit there
what's in here
look at all the people
who's with her
so welcome everybody
we're gonna read this book
first
my mic work
you two move and
everyone here should know
I have to yell
Okay
this is
this book is called I just
want to say good night
everyone see
wanna go down
and it's by
the writer of this
book is Rachel Isadora
who is this lady right here
my mother
she's my mom
here's the first page
Oh
on the African felt
there is a village
as the Sun sets parents
tell their children
it's time for bed
lalla greets her papa
who has been fishing
who you caught a
big one she says
yes it was a good
day Papa says to Lala
it's time for bed
Papa tells Lola
I just want to say goodnight
to the fish Lala says
come Lala mama says
I just want to say
goodnight to the cat Lala says
does anyone have a cat know who
you have a cat
anyone else have a cat
oh back there
anybody else have a cat
not up
we got him already
it's getting late mama calls
I just want to say goodnight
to the bird Lala says
anybody the bird
does anyone have a bird
no
no birds
who likes birds
you like birds
everybody likes birds
you do
Lala it's time to go
I just want to say
goodnight to the goat
why Allah says
yes what they have boots
does anybody have a goat
he has a goat
has anybody seen a goat
yes
oh here's a good one
it's time to go to
sleep mama says
I just want to say good
night to the monkey Wawa says
all right
whoo does anybody have a monkey
yeah
no
are you sure
are you positive
you saw a monkey
Wow
come now mama says
I just want to take
a night to the church
has anybody seen a chicken
yeah
what
do you know what they sound like
do you know what sound they make
no
do they go trip
a rooster
oh there you go
Oh Lala mama says
I just want to say good night
to the little ant Lalo says
does everybody know what ant are
little bugs
I'm just not ready to go to
sleep Lalo says to her dog
who has a dog
yes
good job
you have a dog too and a cat
you're so lucky
does anybody else have a dog
a doggie
you have a dog
you have a doggie too
who loves their doggies
you do
let's go now llama says
yes yes
I am coming
I just want to say goodnight
to the rock Lalo says
who's that
anyone have a pet rock
lalla gets into bed
sweet dreams mama says
goodnight mama says Lola
everybody say goodnight to Lola
goodnight Lola
wait she says
I just want to say
goodnight to my book
Who
who has a book at home
you do
who else has a book
you
you definitely have a book
you do
how many
you have five
oh my gosh
do they all not want to
go to bed like well ago
you should ask them
no no you see
good night moon Lalo
whispers and smiles
everybody say good night moon
and here's the last page
this is the end of this book
good job
everybody's got lots
of animals don't they
and what's the color
you see most in it
pink
right
pink likes pink
alright
so now we're going to do
a finger play about a bird
and this is from a book
in the library collection
that was published in 1915
and it's called mother
Goose finger plays
by Irene Margaret Cullison 1915
so this is called
little robin redbreast
so we're going to make a Robin
so take your hand and fold
in your inner fingers
and there's your Robin
so that's his head
and that's a tail
and then your other hand
is going to be a fence
or they call it a rail okay
so little robin redbreast
and then he's going
to sit on the rail
he's going to wiggle his head
and then his tail
okay and the tune goes
oh I've forgotten the two
little robin redbreast
side up on the rail
little knot oh boy
little motto went ahead
and waggle went his tail
little robin redbreast
sat upon a rail
little Nardo went his head
and waggle went his tail
one more time
little robin redbreast
sat upon a real
little Nardo went his head
and waggle went his tail
alright so now we're gonna do
another one from that same book
and i think you know it
it's a little bit different
pat-a-cake pat-a-cake
so pat-a-cake pat-a-cake
Baker's man
so I will master
as fast as I can
so that lines different
Pat it and prick it
and Mark it with a tea
tea for Thomas and put it
in the oven for baby and me
pat-a-cake pat-a-cake
Baker's man
so I will master
as fast as I can
Pat it and pick it and
Mark it with the tea
and put it in the
oven for baby and me
okay so now Jill is going
to read I hear a pickle
howdy Carolyn okay
who knows what a pickle is
did you eat one okay
anybody else
oh you know pickles
did you eat a pickle
you do
oh you're gonna like
this book I think
one comes to depth
my five senses
I the first one is what I hear
then should I hear in your ear
I smell right
I see
oh you want to sit with me
you can come sit with me
you have to pick you up
we're just taking a
little break a quick pause
are you very comfy
alright there we go
alright we're back okay
what's the next sense
you can tell me
I touch fingers and I
taste with your mouth right
okay we first we here
tweet-tweet tweet-tweet
what makes that sound
who goes tweet tweet
tweet tweet tweet tweet
Abbi that's a good
guess what else
who else goes tweet tweet tweet
in the trees and they a bird
good job
Now
now what goes cluck oohs
buzz buzz buzz buzz buzz
you know
Abby
and what sound is a worm make
a worm
I don't think it
makes any sound right
no sound for the worm okay
I hear the ocean
in a shell who knows
what that sounds like
right the ocean
and what about the waves
splash splash splash
and what about the seagull
what sound does this evil
me what does it go call
that was good that was good
alright
now I hear
I hear grandma
what is grandma say
she says hello
hello on the phone
grandma says hello right and
we hear the music and we dance
who knows how to dance
you know how to dance
you want to show us how
do you dance oh very good
yay
who else knows how to dance
he's dancing back there
what did this
Claire do you know how to dance
do you know how to
do you know you don't want to
that's okay
I hear the drums
oh boy thanks for visiting
who knows
who knows how to play the drums
a lot of drummers
lots of drummer and
oh here's a good one
what about the vacuum
what sound does the
vacuum cleaner me right
and what about what about
like the cars what
sound do they make
BP BP right Phoebe
the cars in the street
Phoebe
you got it
you must have heard a car before
that's right it's a what oh
it was drums yeah remember
and what about
what about cats what
sounded cats me
they go they go meow
and they also go / right they go
/ right
yeah
exactly
I hear the rain
who knows what rain sounds like
who's heard mean
as it goes does it go
swish swish
and what about thunder
thunder those boom
right
boom
can you do that
good job
that's more lightning
but that's fine
no no thunder
what about I hear
the snow falling
what does that sound like
I don't think there's any sound
no sound right there so
what about cheering cheering
yeah
now we go to smell
with your nose right
I smell the soap
who knows what soap smells like
smells nice and clean
I smell mommy's perfume
I smell my blankie
do you have a blankie
who has a blanky
that they sleep with
no one
oh very good
oh you have a blankie
I smell the baby's poop
who has a baby
who has a big
you have a baby
Where
who
has it
where are the babies
there's a baby
where
there's another baby right there
there's a baby
there's so many babies
there's one
who has a big brother
a big brother
shoes stinky sneakers
pinky speakers
I smell
I smell toast
who knows toast
she eats toast bread
who eats bread bread
move what do we move on to
another book all right
I'll skip some
we're gonna go straight ahead to
Oh see see see
with your eyes
I see the airplane
where's the airplane
Outside
right
where's the airplane
is it up
yeah up right
I see
I see the lamp
where's the lamp
right here
but are there any
lamps in this room
there's a lamp right there
it's dark
oh there's
there's
oh the airplanes right there
what about
I see my books
where the books
here are the books right here
I see the books right
oh hi it's okay you can
say yeah you can sit
Okay
oh thank you
I see
where's the moon
in the sky
is it in the sky
is the moon in the sky
hi
should we keep skipping
are we done yeah
all right one more last one
I touch
what do you touch
with your hands right
your fingers
I touch
I touch the doggie
how do you touch the doggie
you put the doggie like this
that's a doggie like that
oh here's a good one
I touched the cupcake
who likes cupcakes
you do
what about you
yes what about you yes
likes cupcakes
you like cupcakes
you do
all right last one
let's do the pickles
all right who knows pickles
all right
Jim dude can you taste the
pickle what does it taste like
sour very good right
and what does it feel
like when you touch it
with your visit slippery
yeah it's slippery
all right I think we're
done with this book
it's the end yeah
thank you for helping me read it
are we reading this
other book or now no oh
they're getting wet
okay so we have another
another action run
from mother Goose fingerplays
and it's goes here
we go up up up
here we go down down down
here we go backwards
and forwards
here we go up
here we go down downtown
here we go up up up
here we go down down down
here we go backwards
and forwards
here we go round
round round me oh
okay let's do our
Twinkle Twinkle song
so get your little
twinkles going
twinkle twinkle little star
how I wonder what you are
so high
like a diamond in the sky
twinkle twinkle little star
how I wonder what you are
all right
so now we're gonna say good Bob
it's just the opposite
of our hello song
so goodbye in sign is
just a little wave okay
so same thing goodbye friends
goodbye friends
and then it's time
to say goodbye
goodbye friends
it's time to say goodbye
all right thank you and
goodbye to our friends
out in the net thank you.
This has been a presentation
from the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.GOV.